okay for people joining this meeting we
are looking at uh things to do with
machine learning
and the calibration of probabilities
so let's start off with the idea
this this i think we saw last time
maybe we should go directly to the third
uh section
in the diagram and maybe i could
re-explain with the diagram
i remember we went on a bad route last
time for the explanations
so basically the idea of this diagram is
that
so on the x-axis you have the predicted
probability
and then right on the y-axis you have
actual probabilities
um this means that um
if you take let's take let's take the
the one where the x-axis is 0.1
it mean if i take everything that i
predicted with 10
of chance everything that the classifier
on a test set
predicted with 10 of chance and look at
all of them and i counted how many times
the prediction was true
and it was true only one percent of the
time
so that's kind of what this this thing
means every time you see a 10
probability
in any context like it doesn't matter if
the 10 percent were the top probability
or not the top probability uh just
anytime there's ten percent
and there's a little bean of course
because it's never exactly ten percent
so
yes among the predictions that were
around ten percent which is very
surprised that that
that the mapping is you know everything
around ten percent ends up being one
percent
that isn't just a big spread
what does that have okay so
so that's that's i mean why are the
error bars so small
it's big it's because of the number of
uh so this is just the the
standard error i mean actually it's more
complex than that but whatever
uh it's because there's a enough example
in the bin
to have a smaller bar so we we don't
care about the spread actually because
it's either one or zero right it's each
example is either
the prediction is correct i mean you
know that case is not correct because
you just it's just 10
so there could be something else at 30
percent but anyway
either it's realized so you pretty ten
percent of cat
so either it is a cat or it's not a cat
so just a bunch of one and zero and you
can put the average of that
so it's an average and so average is
zero point zero one
and uh with the standard deviation
that i showed here because we have a
finite
test size if you were a test set there
was you know
millions of examples you would have no
uh
error bars and actually one of the
things that i spent a lot of time on
is to appropriately choose the number of
beans
like like in a you know automatic
histogram
because you want to kind of balance the
the
[Music]
the number of beans with the errors
in each beans if you have few beans you
have big arrows but you only have few
beans so
poor resolution but if you have a lot of
beans then you can have
a less example in each peanut so you
have large
arrows okay let me try this again trying
to understand what you're doing here
okay so the classifier
says it's a dog
it says there's a point one percent
probability that it's a dog
for example okay
and now we look at the training set
and we say that's it tests that
we say you said
that there was a 0.1 probability
of these hundred pictures you said that
you implied that 10 of them were dogs
okay but actually only one of them is a
dog
that's what you're saying here is that
correct not
not exactly because i mix all the
classes
it's just i take any time you say
10 percent of chance for something all
right okay fine fine
i'll put them together let's let's ask
the question
for there's a different measure which
says for a dog specifically
yeah what you're saying is you're taking
all the things that are predicted
probability around point one and there
might be things with point nine
nine one point one point one two et
cetera et cetera et cetera
yeah yeah those are all being binned
you your auto bending in some way yeah
right
so you're saying
that um
okay so you're saying for the things
that
were those probabilities everything that
had about that probability
look at how often it actually showed up
exactly
exactly okay okay
so now what do we expect i mean i
understand what this curve is i
understand what that line is i
understand all that
so what are you going to do with this
this result other than just look at it
and say it's good it's bad
so well
for classify the calibration is
internal so if you see that it's bad
you can read shrine and setting
calibration to true
which currently is a hidden option but
we could think of making it the top of
the option
otherwise it's mainly you know all right
so you are re-tweet
it actually you have a go ahead go ahead
yeah yeah actually so sorry
in the general case somebody gave you a
classifier and it you see it's badly
calibrated
what you do is that you train a model to
calibrate it
i mean okay or or you could change your
your training procedure so
let's say it's a neural network and and
you see it's badly calibrated so for
classify it's kind of automatic
calibration right but if it's a neural
network
and you see if it's badly calibrated you
could either go back to your training
procedure and understand why
it's badly calibrated maybe you are
overfitting in some way
um maybe you know your way to to prevent
overfitting you were looking at the
wrong metric you were looking working
accuracy where you should have been
looking at the likelihood or something
like that
or you do a post-processing which is
just a little model
that takes the probabilities as input
and return new probabilities
as output so it's kind of correcting the
probabilities
yeah i understand sounds exceptionally
dangerous but i that
you know no more dangerous than a lot of
what people do in machine learning yeah
i mean it's it's one of those things
where it's like
we got it wrong but we're going to hack
it i mean it it's very much like a
you know it's it's in the my crocodile
ate my homework
type or or i don't know what it is you
know it's a very
s yeah i i completely agree that i
i mean i'm not 100 sure on this topic
but but i feel that when a new network
is
badly calibrated which apparently they
many most are
most modern neural network for example
training images
are badly calibrated and i believe that
there's something wrong
i believe that that it's um well i'm
always surprised when we look at the
probabilities
for you know it's very very certain that
it's a snake
for example exactly who's certain that
it's a snake
exactly well that's a problem of
calibration and that's typically they
are overconfident yeah neural networks
trinomial images
modern neurotoxin images uh in the
classic way
are typically overconfident so they look
more like like not this one
yeah they look like that one okay so so
let's talk about the names for these
things
okay no actually the other one sorry
they look like the other one what was
the difference between this
so so this one is under confidence like
this is the same
i mean these pictures here reliability
diagram and classic reliability diagram
what's the
yeah so so uh the same data
is just the the scaling that is
different the scaling function
okay okay one is the logic scaling and
everybody does this classic
thing that's why i call it classic
but i think people should the one that
has a logic scale because you can see
well things that are near zero and
you're one
and you see it's it's a nice straight
line otherwise it's like this weird
s-curve uh
yeah well it's interesting it's a
straight line is it obvious why it's a
straight line
no uh it could be anything
uh but but as it happens it often
what does this look like if you do it on
our image
image identification network what does
this look like
i didn't do that but i'm pretty pretty
confident that it would be overconfident
so right so it would look like
uh yeah on the opposite you know like
the symmetric with respect to the
diagonal
um confident one
actually yeah that's why it's often line
is because typically
it's a matter of overconfidence under
confidence in a general sense it could
be anything
you couldn't say you know yeah yeah but
why on a logic
scale should it be a straight line
that's what i'm asking ah
yeah um
i don't know exactly but it's good for
us to to change it because the model
to calibrate you you just change the
the what we call the temperature of the
probability distribution
uh it's called temperature scaling so
basically you just
multiply the lo go the probabilities by
a number and then you you do a soft max
again
and and this is enough to calibrate
most models so extremely simple
calibration model and works pretty well
so
that's what we have implemented
currently in uh
in classify but arguably you could other
model
to calibrate
look i think this should be called
something like probability recalibration
arrow true or false
one thing though i realize we could make
it a little bit more generic
uh with predict so it doesn't really
make
sense for predict to calibrating the
probabilities
uh like yeah i understand but there's
not a different
operation calibrating the values
recalibration exactly exactly it's more
about calibrating the values
it's it's more about a post-processing
function really
and uh and in a sense this calibration
this so okay my idea was
you know following the rule that you
know roger told me a few times
um that option that i true for that
generally bad design
so you know can we make a sort of
calibrate or function or you know or
probably calibrator and then the user
can can also have a
custom model and they put it in
and for classify this function would
take
an association of probabilities i think
that's the only way to do
and return a new association of
probabilities but for predict you would
just take a value and return a value
to be stupid to do something else
because that's yeah
like like you won't give a distribution
it doesn't make sense uh
i mean it could make sense but simpler
to think in
um putting a function rather than a
so why not a recalibration function
yeah that could be something like that
yeah yeah
and then yeah i was thinking
we should follow because we're feature
extractor and we have
anomaly detector so maybe it should be
just by consistency to have something
and
in awe even though it's sometimes not
very pretty
i don't think it's a good idea um i
think it's a recalibration function
because i don't think that
that unless function yeah yeah right
okay so here
i mean it will be something like
probability calibration diagram
yeah that's probability calibration data
yeah
the two standard name uh is either
reliability diagram or calibration curve
that's a two standard that's why in the
title in the in the
plot label i put you know parenthesis
calibration curve
but i don't think you should call it
that i think should just call it
probability calibration
okay yeah at least i can diagram a
probability calibration curve would be
okay i think
i don't think reliability is the right
thing i mean reliability
is like uh you know we are reliable
but it's just i think i mean yeah far
away from that concept
yeah yeah i mean that
in statistics they call it like this
uh yeah well they call a lot of things
strange names and statistics
doesn't help mostly 100 years old
sorry no go ahead
um
okay and i think this notion i like
actual probability well
if it's the probability in the test set
why not say actual probability in test
set
predicted probability
okay that's better actual frequency and
test set
okay actual frequency would be good just
predicted probability
actual frequency yeah it makes it a bit
clearer otherwise like what
do they say there's no probability right
yeah wren on our live stream is asking
how are we defining actual probability
yeah if you have an image of a cat or
either is a cat or it isn't a cat
yes exactly exactly the um
unless it's one of those never mind
um thinking of all the variant
you know pseudo cats um
okay so then then we'd say actual
frequency predictive probability actual
frequency here
and then and at the top it would say
probability calibration diagram
actually why are we giving a title at
the top do we need a title
oh no no i thought
but i thought it would be nice to well
it's not clear that it helps
i mean if you're seeing predictive
probability an actual frequency
that's kind of telling you what it is
for for someone that knows yes but well
but it's not helping you
to say probability calibration all right
well probability calibration diagram at
the top wouldn't be bad
okay so then
then
i would not label it i don't see the
point i mean it's clear what that line
is
this side um
i think it's nice to to remind and
people can always select it like it's uh
legendary so they really won't put in
their reports
you know they remove that pretty easily
how do they remove it
just click on the on the left and copy
paste for example
yeah oh i see this is uh
fairly well contained i i i know i like
to explain a bit i think a lot of
especially this concept is really
elusive to some
and well yes we spent an hour talking
so you know
i do the same for this comparison plot
you have a sort of of uh you know that
on the x-axis it's it's for predict it's
the value
the predicted value and the y-axis is
the actual value
and so you have a better scatter plot
right and so i'll put a line as well and
it's like perfect
prediction line or something like that
all right okay okay
well you could leave off the word line
you could just say perfect calibration
yeah yeah it's true
yeah definitely um
okay so then this would be probability
calibration diagram
and you could say classic probability or
linear probability calibration diagram
or classic whatever you want i wouldn't
call it classic because it's only
classic today
the etienne one may become classic in
the future i actually hope so
you know i i think it's wrong i think
it's wrong it's really nothing
well fine so then say linear probability
calibration diagram
yeah with the other one yeah okay
um okay so then here we
probability calibration data
what is this anyway it's that of the
curve that's it
which many people would like then they
can do really you know
the plot they want fine fine
all right and this would be
a recalibration function arrow automatic
or true or whatever it is
down here
yeah yeah that's uh and that would be a
symbol
yep
okay let's just do it
i think that's it and on the bottom you
can see i mean yeah we already discussed
about
it but basically that would be the way
this function would work
that it would take an association of
probability and return the assertion of
probability and
all value and return the value for
predict
sorry what what are you saying here so
this this calibration function
would uh would work like that for
classify and for predict it would just
take the value and return a new value
like that that would be the it's spec
uh if someone thank you i'm thinking i'm
thinking i'm thinking
well actually no sorry i don't think so
log probability
why isn't it just taking a probability
wasn't the the classifier
because then it could produce
a probability that is not valid
where if it's log i can i always do a
soft max
i mean it's kind of the natural wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
okay i thought this function was just
going to take a number
0.1 i'm going to return another number
0.01 or something
i didn't think it was going to know
anything yeah yes yes yes okay okay okay
i i forgot to
mention that so my definition of
um calibration is a little bit
re or you say reducing simplified
the true definition is more general
and you cannot represent it in the
diagram
because it's multi-dimensional it's
among
all the examples that have p1 for class
1
p2 4 class 2 p3 for class 3 and so on
among all these examples and of course
you need to have a big test set if you
take this definition
uh you know you bin the example that are
near
these values of probabilities and then
you look
at the realization one is you know the
percent the frequency of class one
frequency of class two frequency of
class three
that's kind of a more generic yeah i
understand
yeah it hasn't that hasn't squashed you
down to just saying there's a certain
probability it's saying
where do the probabilities come from i
mean here you're taking
what we discussed before you're taking
all things
exactly lizards whatever that had a
predictive probability of around point
so it's a it's a weaker definition but
that's okay to visualize it and
often it's you know i mean i think okay
but but you want both things
right you want the possibility of having
um
just a pure probability changer
as well as the possibility of having a
probability changer by class
i mean i think the more generic thing is
is uh
honestly you rarely
uh i mean i think i think the more
generic one is
is enough um
wait a second what you would be doing
here
is simply taking this curve and
twisting it right you're just going to
have some function
that's what you did here right took that
curve
to get that calibrated thing you took
that curve and you just
mapped 0.99 to whatever that it is down
there
right actually no actually no the way
it's trained
is it's it's you know it's kicking in
the
original you know n-dimensional space so
to speak
it's learning a model so let's say yeah
this n-class or n-probability
it's learning a function uh you know
input end-to-end okay i'm lost because i
i thought what we were doing was
we have probabilities that we get out
right yes that have been already
aggregated
across i mean it's a weird thing to do
but all things
you know dogs crocodiles teacups
they all have you know probability point
one and those are the things that enter
that bin there the probability points
yes right
okay so now one thing you can do is to
say everything with probability around
point
one or probability around point five or
something
should be remapped to being something
with probability right yes
yes okay since we use a simple model
that's basically what what we're doing
there's a
but okay but in general you could you
could it
could depend on the class right if you
knew the class
because your recalibration function then
is basically a post-processor a general
post-processor that's taking
from that class but this isn't even
right i mean this isn't even right
because it's a function right given a
probability p1
that is 0.726 you're then returning for
that
class the probability should be
something else
right yes but you have to know that the
probability have to be normalized right
so
so it needs to be re-normalized in the
end that's what
you cannot really change one probability
on its own look it doesn't make any
sense it doesn't make sense
your classifier just gave you a certain
probability for the class of elements
yeah yeah yeah okay but this thing that
you gave here this
this oh i see what you're saying you're
saying you you
that's why what probabilities you're
giving for all those classes
yeah and then this gives you what okay
fine
but but you can in fact do okay so the
simpler cases you just take the
calibration diagram
and you simply apply a function to the
values in the calibration diagram to
give
new values right
that's the simplest case and that's the
analog of this case here
um yes because in this case here
the analog of doing this would be to say
give the input i mean
yeah yeah and do a normalization you can
have a function
that takes indeed a probability and
independently it takes each probability
transform them
right and then you after we normalize
absolutely
well actually i don't think you do have
to re-normalize because the truth is
that you know for many purposes it's
just oh you said it was probably 0.9 i'm
going to say it's actually probability
0.7
the global normalization of that is
irrelevant
uh uh yeah but i mean it's kind of a
contract we have when you have a
classifier
you know it gives you a probability of
uh
what are the possible classes a valid
distribution of those
classes then you might have to analyze
okay but but i mean
this okay so you've got two cases either
the recalibration function
takes a value a probability value or
an output value in the case of of
predict and returns a new value
or it takes a richer set of things which
in the case of prediction
would be not the analog of this
would be if you've got a predictor pred
that takes
x and returns y okay then
what you do for the recalibration
function is
the analog of this would be to say
give me both x and y and i will give you
back
uh you know y prime basically
so what i'm saying because that's the
analog of saying well what class was it
in
no no you don't give x here no you do
if you're going the analog of this case
you give x
because otherwise you're just saying the
value i got
was y so we normalize y yes exactly
right but i'm saying that the the you're
saying the value i got
for a particular class class was p1
and i'm giving you the class p1 i'm not
just telling you the value you got was
p1
so i'm saying the analog for the
predictor
of the of this form right we've got two
forms
right we've got we've got the pure
pure numerical renormalization okay
and then we've got the you know context
dependent renormalization
but but okay in the classifier you don't
give the input
i right so so it's just
the in it's just two different lists the
classifier
gives a vector of probabilities and
predict gives
a distribution over numeric values
so so okay the full analog would be that
you give the distribution
of a y to the calibrator
right one is is distribution on the
categorical space the other one
prediction numeric space
but giving a distribution to the
calibrator
it's a big kind of work yeah it's been
kind of worms it's much easier to work
with the value and in the end you can
still transform distributions
by defining a function so it means that
if you query the distribution it's going
to be the transform distribution
by this calibrator
and and that's fine
i think
i don't see how any mere mortal is going
to write a recalibration function
it's i i
yeah i think it's sort of pointless to
offer it i mean
look you can have recalibration function
arrow automatic or none
and that's fine but what it does in this
case
seems to me difficult
and it might make more sense if you were
to just give
you know given a probability how should
you don't realize or maybe what you feed
to the recalibration function is some
kind of complicated association
yeah that can have a bunch of things in
it where it can pick out what it needs
you you can be a bit smart by having all
the probabilities
uh it's true that many methods they just
focus on single probabilities
modify them a bit independently and then
normalizing
but you can be a bit smart if you have
especially if you have a large
large calibration set let's call it
uh you can start having models that are
a little bit smarter and uh
so but under what circumstances the
recalibration function is called
only once is that a true statement or is
it called on every piece of i
when is the reward only once on the
output probably all the vector
probabilities
or this association of probabilities and
give the new association of
probabilities
except sometimes you just want it to be
a function that it's just
saying you know some function of a of a
single piece of i
making right so you've got two cases
you've got the case where you want to
give the whole thing
you've got the case where you just want
to give one of them
yeah um except of course when you have
the whole thing you have
one of them as well so you know the
association
if i want like the classic one is just
uh this temperature scaling is just a
power like you take this probability you
do power 0.5
and then you re-normalize okay
well but okay but fine but but then then
that should be
the you know recalibration function
arrow square root and actually actually
yes that's pretty good you know
something like that it allows you to
change the temperature
uh directly and that's super classic you
can do it by hand
uh like this is good
these people will use that fine but i
mean but then
but then okay so the problem is if you
give recalibration function
arrow a function here
right the question is how do you have an
escape valve that allows you to give
allows the system to feed in this whole
giant vector whole giant association
you want both cases you want both the
case well you're being fed in peace of
eyes and in case we were being fed in
the whole association right
i think this look this sqrt will work on
the association right
so well it will actually yes yes so it
means that
we are good yes yes yes yes
all right fair enough i see what you're
saying so your basic claim is if i take
this
this association here and i've made a
function
so if i say square root of that
association
yeah if because they are i mean
because they are listable uh it will
work
of course if you do a custom function
that work on only one value it won't
work
but i think in 90 of cases where you
just use
functions like that it will just work
fine fine that's nice
all right and automatic will involve
you doing whatever yeah some methods
are calibrated submitted or not and um
yeah oh there's one thing i don't know
in that
in that how could we specify
please calibrate everything i mean by
calibrating everything like
we have the calibrate none right i mean
recalibration function goes to none
recognition goes to automatic and what
would be the case for
what what if we calibrate everything
what does that mean so it means there's
a bunch of methods
and in automatic for example random
forest is going to be recalibrated
gradient boosted tree is not because
it's already calibrated
it's so we're just a recalibration
function arrow all
and have it do everything oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah
exactly automatic non all or function
okay that's good the square root like
it's a temperature scaling it's
people might like to do it just by hand
by saying oh it feels a little bit
too too you know too big peak in my
distribution let's just
smooth smooth the stream a little bit
and
uh let's see ethan is commenting why
when you do inference you need to be
able to change the temperature
manually well that's what it is
that's what it is yeah yeah yeah in some
models like this
so yeah gpt so these language models
they offer a way for you to change the
temperature
of the the you know the
distribution of next characters
and so you can create something that is
a bit more you know
exploratory or something that is a
little bit more
predict you know the most likely
character
right because it's this is famous
example of this language model trainer
wikipedia
and if you put a temperature of zero it
does something like
the united states of the united states
of the united states of the united
states
because it's the most likely thing but
it's not really
[Music]
you know typical so ethan says in
general it should be automatically
optimized with grid search
well that's that's what's happening in
classify like the
the calibration is is a basically a
model that is trained to calibrate
as good as possible
fair enough
um pretty well like if you scroll up
like i was i was so surprised
this this let's say the wrong run for us
so this is
for devon this is um some kind of crazy
error
can you screencap that please yep yeah i
just got it
that's it means you're not getting this
email but uh
um the um uh okay
um okay sorry random forest oh you know
i was just saying like the
to cheer up a little bit uh if you
scroll up like the first example
uh yeah so you know that's that's this
you seen it like this diagram where it's
not calibrated at all
it's completely underconfident and if
you scroll down a bit
yeah i saw it you can call it and so
that's a new
now in class when you use classified
that's what happens now
[Music]
what does it do to image identified does
it make image identify more sensible
we haven't calibrated it so that that
would be for the next version of
emergency file that would be really
great if we calibrate it uh
i think and i definitely we should i
think we should try a new one soon
because
now there's there are some models that
are that are quite better so we should
use them
fine all right
sounds good this was easy he says
cool yep it's it's this is the moment
where people say and there's just one
last thing
and that turns out not to be easy at all
um do you need this file or can i
just uh get rid of i think
yeah that would be good although i mean
it's all recorded so
fine i will stop sorry
no problem no problem um
you're on that framework calibration
meeting two
great okay sounds good all right
well thanks thanks everyone thanks to
folks on the live stream i think there's
another live stream for people who are
interested there is another one coming
up
in about an hour and a half so
uh talk to you all soon okay bye-bye